we begin with breaking news out of Egypt
a huge fire has engulfed a security
directorate of the city of ismailia it's
on the West Bank of the Suez Canal
now there are reports of casualties that
these are recent pictures of the fire in
full blaze a number of people are
believed to be trapped inside now
ismaili is one of the key cities
overlooking Egypt's Suez Canal a vital
Waterway between Asia and Europe that
sees about 10 percent of the world's
Maritime trade now we'll bring you more
details on this as we get it but now
let's bring in a side select he's a
professor of political sociology and he
joins us live from Cairo
uh Professor thank you for joining us
um whatever the reason for this fire the
fact that it's happened at a security
directorate is going to be alarming for
the Egyptian government right
of course because it also
[Music]
all sorts of July very mysterious
incident in which some security
Personnel were killed the government had
not
disclosed the cause of the violence that
happened and who was behind it and so
this is another incident that is not
clear what is happening the headquarter
of the ismaili security is isolated in
the city so it's not adjacent to any uh
public building or Museum or anything
and the the way it happened it just
again it's not uh
you know very assuring because it
doesn't look like just an incident
somebody's cooking uh this is a very
complicated uh fire and uh what we know
is that inside this building you always
have recruits you have officers and it
happened very early in the morning so
most likely you will have a very high
toll of victims uh resulting from that
uh incident so far the the government
had not
cleared what is the cause of this fire
and what happened but we Now understand
that the hospitals in uh in ismaili have
been on a left because they are
expecting
some casualties we don't know how many
dead and how many would be uh wounded
it's too early because this happened
very early in the morning and that also
shows that it could it could have a very
high high level of high tall of victims
so let's just talk about the Egyptian
government right now it's always been
very tight-lipped when it comes to
security and as you just mentioned there
there have been a couple of incidents in
recent months including this one uh that
the Egyptian government haven't really
released that kind of detail on do you
think that they'll be under any kind of
pressure to release details or do you
think they'll keep to the strategy of
remaining tight-lipped
uh you know unlike the incident that
happened in El Irish in Sinai which was
isolated in the desert nobody knows
anything this one you cannot deny it or
be silent because uh this is in the city
near the city and the people are
watching it is all over the social media
people are using the mobile and they are
recording and revealing the Egyptian TV
channels the private and public began
also to cover what is happening so it is
very difficult that you uh the
government would remain silent on what
happened uh not this time now we are
seeing pictures of the building these
are daylight pictures they've been shot
in the last hour or so I think the
building is still smoking this was a
huge fire
um and it's something that I mean the
the investigation of this is going to
take a while but do you think are you
hearing that the security services the
emergency Services were simply
overwhelmed by the sheer scale the sheer
size of this fire
uh of course what we are seeing is the
reaction that shows that the LC is
something very big and it is not clear
what cool subject like that so quickly
and in such a huge building it's not a
small building
uh and so and of course like any uh big
government and security building though
a lot of
anti-autumn uh uh file system
uh why it didn't work why this is so big
uh again this has to wait until there is
the public investigation if they reveal
what is happening then we will know what
really happened lots of unanswered
questions there Professor Seitz joining
us from Cairo thank you so much